one of the unique differentiators and
one of the unique ways in which we're
approaching the whole cloud message the
whole mobile message is really around
you know the whole IOT message the role
analytics message is really around this
notion of digital transformation it's
the business reason behind the
challenges that are being put in front
of our clients and those particular
challenges are in essence basically
creating the environment around which we
are building out our standards building
out our cloud platform on those
standards delivering it to then enable
them to incorporate whatever
capabilities they actually need in order
to be able to re-architect and rebuild
their supply chains and value chains
into a coherent set of applications
around this notion of digital
transformation what is digital
transformation it means that basically
all of the individual data streams that
are coming in through the internet
whether it's through mobile whether it's
through Internet of Things each and
every single one of those opportunities
presented to our clients then force
those particular opportunities to then
be manifested through digital outreach
okay so whether or not I'm trying to
create a new customer relationship
whether or not I'm trying to incorporate
better information about asset
management so I can run my planes more
effectively or you know essentially
build a more engaging experience around
my automotive you know the automobiles
that I manufacture and deliver in one
form or another that creates you know a
tremendous amount of pressure on our
clients to then create that kind of
digital experience
our hybrid strategy is fundamentally
based on re-architecting and reorienting
digital supply chains and digital value
chains in an open environment that
leverages cloud as a delivery mechanism
it's not an end in and of itself and
that's something that I think we
uniquely bring to the market we allow
people more entry points into that kind
of transformation than anybody else on
the platform and anybody else on the
planet so basically we give people
tremendous degrees of freedom and
flexibility and actually moving
applications into a digital world more
so than any of our competitors the thing
that's most important for us to
understand in being successful in cloud
is that clients want to consume our
capabilities in a completely different
way and that pushing the old style of
computing is not going to work it's not
in line with their needs and wants and
they're just going to push back and
essentially not allow us to succeed in
the old consuming models probably the
most important thing that we can do is
to get an understanding as to how we
bring together all of our capabilities
so that they can consume it in a digital
and consumable way the most important
aspect of that transformation has to
manifest itself with developers
developers are key if we can not you
know reach out to them and build them a
platform that allows them to put
together those particular capabilities
in a coherent way across the board we
will not succeed in the transformation
that we
make across all of our capabilities to
then deliver through cloud in essence
basically our differentiation is in that
flexibility is in providing a coherent
view of an open environment and in
putting that open environment together
and in delivering it in as many
different ways as our clients want to
consume it in order to be able to
execute that digital transformation